>> MADAM VICE PRESIDENT, FELLOW
AMERICANS, I STATE THE OBVIOUS,
ONE YEAR AGO TODAY, IN THIS
SACRED PLACE, DEMOCRACY WAS
ATTACKED, SIMPLY ATTACKED.
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE WAS UNDER
ASSAULT, THE CONSTITUTION, OUR
CONSTITUTION FACED THE GRAVEST
OF THREATS, OUTNUMBERED IN THE
FACE OF A BRUTAL ATTACK, THE
CAPITOL POLICE, THE D.C.
METROPOLITAN POLICE DEPARTMENT,
THE NATIONAL GUARD, AND OTHER
BRAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
SAVED THE RULE OF LAW.
OUR DEMOCRACY HELD.
WE, THE PEOPLE, ENDURED.
WE, THE PEOPLE, PREVAILED.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OUR
HISTORY, A PRESIDENT HAD NOT
JUST LOST AN ELECTION, HE TRIED
TO PREVENT THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER
OF POWER AS A VIOLENT MOB
BREACHED THE CAPITOL.
BUT THEY FAILED.
THEY FAILED.
AND ON THIS DAY OF REMEMBRANCE
WE MUST MAKE SURE THAT SUCH
ATTACK NEVER, NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
I'M SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY FROM
STATUARY HALL, IN THE UNITED
STATES CAPITOL.
THIS IS WHERE THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES MET FOR 50 YEARS
IN THE DECADES LEADING UP TO THE
CIVIL WAR.
THIS IS -- ON THIS FLOOR, WHERE
YOUNG CONGRESSMAN FROM ILLINOIS,
ABRAHAM LINCOLN, SAT AT DESK
191.
ABOVE HIM, ABOVE US, OVER THAT
DOOR, LEADING INTO THE ROTUNDA,
IS A SCULPTURE DEPICTING CLEO,
THE MUSE OF HISTORY.
IN HER HANDS AN OPEN BOOK IN
WHICH SHE RECORDS THE EVENTS
TAKING PLACE IN THIS CHAMBER
BELOW.
CLEO STOOD WATCH OVER THIS HALL,
ONE YEAR AGO TODAY, AS SHE HAS
FOR MORE THAN 200 YEARS.
SHE RECORDED WHAT TOOK PLACE,
REAL HISTORY, THE REAL FACTS,
THE REAL TRUTH.
THE FACTS AND THE TRUTH THAT
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS JUST
SHARED AND THAT YOU AND I AND
THE WHOLE WORLD SAW WITH OUR OWN
EYES.
THE BIBLE TELLS US THAT WE SHALL
KNOW THE TRUTH, AND THE TRUTH
SHALL MAKE US FREE.
WE SHALL KNOW THE TRUTH.
WELL, HERE IS THE GOD'S TRUTH
ABOUT JANUARY 6th, 2021.
CLOSE YOUR EYES.
GO BACK TO THAT DAY.
WHAT DO YOU SEE?
RIOTERS RAMPAGING, WAVING FOR
THE FIRST TIME INSIDE THIS
CAPITOL, CONFEDERATE FLAG THAT
SYMBOLIZED THE CAUSE TO DESTROY
AMERICA, TO RIP US APART, EVEN
DURING THE CIVIL WAR THAT NEVER,
EVER HAPPENED.
BUT IT HAPPENED HERE IN 2021.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU SEE?
A MOB, BREAKING WINDOWS, KICKING
IN DOORS, BREACHING THE CAPITOL.
AMERICAN FLAGS ON POLES BEING
USED AS WEAPONS, AS SPEARS, FIRE
EXTINGUISHERS BEING THROWN AT
HEADS OF POLICE OFFICERS.
A CROWD ASSAULTED THOSE POLICE
OFFICERS, DRAGGED THEM, SPRAYED
THEM, STOMPED ON THEM.
OVER 140 POLICE OFFICERS WERE
INJURED.
WE ALL HEARD THE POLICE OFFICERS
WHO WERE THERE THAT DAY TESTIFY
TO WHAT HAPPENED.
ONE OFFICER CALLED IT, QUOTE, A
MEDIEVAL BATTLE AND HE WAS MORE
AFRAID THAT DAY THAN HE WAS
FIGHTING THE WAR IN IRAQ.
THEY REPEATEDLY ASKED SINCE THAT
DAY HOW DARE ANYONE, ANYONE
DIMINISH, BELITTLE OR DENY THE
HELL THEY WERE PUT THROUGH.
WE SAW WITH OUR OWN EYES RIOTERS
MEN OUS THESE HALLS, THREATENING
THE LIFE OF THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, LITERALLY ERECTING
GALLOWS TO HANG THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
WHAT DID WE NOT SEE?
WE DIDN'T SEE A FORMER PRESIDENT
WHO HAD JUST RALLIED THE MOB TO
ATTACK, SITTING IN THE PRIVATE
DINING ROOM OFF THE OVAL OFFICE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, WATCHING IT
ALL ON TELEVISION AND DOING
NOTHING FOR HOURS AS POLICE WERE
ASSAULTED, LIVES AT RISK, THE
NATION'S CAPITOL UNDER SIEGE.
THIS WASN'T A GROUP OF TOURISTS.
THIS WAS AN ARMED INSURRECTION.
THEY WEREN'T LOOKING TO UPHOLD
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE.
THEY WERE LOOKING TO DENY THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE.
THEY WERE LOOKING TO UPHOLD --
THEY WEREN'T LOOKING TO UPHOLD A
FREE AND FAIR ELECTION.
THEY WERE LOOKING TO OVERTURN
ONE.
THEY WEREN'T LOOKING TO SAVE THE
CAUSE OF AMERICA, THEY WERE
LOOKING TO SUBVERT THE
CONSTITUTION.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT BEING BOGGED
DOWN IN THE PAST.
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THE PAST ISN'T BURIED.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY FORWARD.
THAT'S WHAT GREAT NATIONS DO.
THEY DON'T BURY THE TRUTH.
THEY FACE UP TO IT.
SOUNDS LIKE HYPERBOLE, IT IS THE
TRUTH, THEY FACE UP TO IT.
WE ARE A GREAT NATION.
MY FELLOW AMERICANS, IN LIFE
THERE IS TRUTH, AND TRAGICALLY
THERE ARE LIVES.
LIES CONCEIVED AND SPREAD FOR
PROFIT AND POWER.
WE MUST BE ABSOLUTELY CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT IS TRUE AND WHAT IS A
LIE.
AND HERE'S THE TRUTH.
A FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA HAS CREATED
AND SPREAD A WEB OF LIES ABOUT
THE 2020 ELECTION.
HE'S DONE SO BECAUSE HE VALUES
POWER OVER PRINCIPLE.
BECAUSE HE SEES HIS OWN INTEREST
AS MORE IMPORTANT THAN HIS
COUNTRY'S INTEREST, AND
AMERICA'S INTEREST.
AND BECAUSE HIS BRUISED EGO
MATTERS MORE TO HIM THAN OUR
DEMOCRACY OR OUR CONSTITUTION.
HE CAN'T ACCEPT HE LOST EVEN
THOUGH THAT'S WHAT 93 UNITED
STATES SENATORS, HIS OWN
ATTORNEY GENERAL, HIS OWN VICE
PRESIDENT GOVERNORS AND STATE
OFFICIALS IN EVERY BATTLEGROUND
STATE HAVE ALL SAID HE LOST.
THAT'S WHAT 81 MILLION OF YOU
DID AS YOU VOTED FOR A NEW WAY
FORWARD.
HE'S DONE WHAT NO PRESIDENT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY, HAS EVER, EVER
DONE.
HE REFUSED TO ACCEPT THE RESULTS
OF AN ELECTION, AND THE WILL OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SOME COURAGEOUS MEN AND WOMEN ON
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY ARE
STANDING AGAINST IT, TRYING TO
UPHOLD THE PRINCIPLE OF THAT
PARTY.
TOO MANY OTHERS ARE TRANSFORMING
THAT PARTY INTO SOMETHING ELSE.
THEY SEEM NO LONGER WANT TO BE
THE PARTY, THE PARTY OF LINCOLN,
EISENHOWER, REAGAN, THE BUSHES.
WHATEVER MY OTHER DISAGREEMENTS
ARE WITH REPUBLICANS TO SUPPORT
THE RULE OF LAW AND NOT THE RULE
OF A SINGLE MAN, I WILL ALWAYS
SEEK TO WORK TOGETHER WITH THEM.
TO FIND SHARED SOLUTIONS WHERE
POSSIBLE, BECAUSE WE HAVE A
SHARED BELIEF IN DEMOCRACY, THEN
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
ANYTHING.
SO AT THIS MOMENT, WE MUST
DECIDE WHAT KIND OF NATION ARE
WE GOING TO BE.
ARE WE GOING TO BE A NATION THAT
ACCEPTS POLITICAL VIOLENCE AS A
NORM, ARE WE GOING TO BE A
NATION WHERE WE ALLOW PARTISAN
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO OVERTURN
THE LEGALLY EXPRESSED WILL OF
THE PEOPLE?
ARE WE GOING TO BE A NATION THAT
LIVES NOT BY THE LIGHT OF THE
TRUTH, BUT IN THE SHADOW OF
LIES?
WE CANNOT ALLOW OURSELVES TO BE
THAT KIND OF NATION.
THE WAY FORWARD IS TO RECOGNIZE
THE TRUTH, TO LIVE BY IT.
THE BIG LIE BEING TOLD BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND MANY
REPUBLICANS WHO FEAR HIS RATH IS
THAT THE INSURRECTION IN THIS
COUNTRY ACTUALLY TOOK PLACE ON
ELECTION DAY, NOVEMBER 3rd,
2020.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
IS THAT WHAT YOU THOUGHT?
IS THAT WHAT YOU THOUGHT WHEN
YOU VOTED THAT DAY?
TAKING PART IN AN INSURRECTION,
IS THAT WHAT YOU THOUGHT YOU
WERE DOING?
OR DID YOU THINK YOU WERE
CARRYING OUT YOUR HIGHEST DUTY
AS A CITIZEN AND VOTING?
FORMER PRESIDENT'S SUPPORTERS
ARE TRYING TO REWRITE HISTORY.
THEY WANT YOU TO SEE ELECTION
DAY AS THE DAY OF INSURRECTION.
AND THE RIOT THAT TOOK PLACE ON
JANUARY 6th AS A TRUE EXPRESSION
OF THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE.
CAN YOU THINK OF A MORE TWISTED
WAY TO LOOK AT THIS COUNTRY, TO
LOOK AT AMERICA?
I CANNOT.
HERE'S THE TRUTH, THE ELECTION
OF 2020 WAS THE GREATEST
DEMONSTRATION, DEMOCRACY, IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
MORE OF YOU VOTED IN THAT
ELECTION THAN HAVE EVER VOTED IN
ALL OF AMERICAN HISTORY.
OVER 150 MILLION AMERICANS WENT
TO THE POLLS AND VOTED THAT DAY.
IN A PANDEMIC.
SOME AT GREAT RISK TO THEIR
LIVES.
THEY SHOULD BE APPLAUDED, NOT
ATTACKED.
RIGHT NOW IN STATE AFTER STATE,
NEW LAWS ARE BEING WRITTEN.
NOT TO PROTECT THE VOTE, BUT TO
DENY IT.
NOT ONLY TO SUPPRESS THE VOTE,
BUT TO SUBVERT IT.
NOT TO STRENGTHEN AND PROTECT
OUR DEMOCRACY, BUT BECAUSE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT LOST INSTEAD OF
LOOKING AT THE ELECTION RESULTS
FROM 2020 AND SAYING THEY NEED
NEW IDEAS OR BETTER IDEAS TO WIN
MORE VOTES.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND
SUPPORTERS HAVE DECIDED THE ONLY
WAY FOR THEM TO WIN IS TO
SUPPRESS YOUR VOTE AND SUBVERT
OUR ELECTIONS.
IT IS WRONG.
IT IS UNDEMOCRATIC.
AND FRANKLY IT IS UN-AMERICAN.
SECOND BIG LIE BEING TOLD BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S SUPPORTERS IS
THAT THE RESULTS OF THE ELECTION
OF 2020 CAN'T BE TRUSTED.
THE TRUTH IS THAT NO ELECTION,
NO ELECTION IN AMERICAN HISTORY
HAS BEEN MORE CLOSELY
SCRUTINIZED OR MORE CAREFULLY
COUNTED.
EVERY LEGAL CHALLENGE
QUESTIONING THE RESULTS AND
EVERY COURT IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN MADE WAS MADE
AND WAS REJECTED, OFTEN REJECTED
BY REPUBLICAN APPOINTED JUDGES,
INCLUDING JUDGES APPOINTED BY
THE FORMER PRESIDENT HIMSELF,
FROM STATE COURTS TO THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT.
RECOUNTS WERE UNDERTAKEN IN
STATE AFTER STATE.
GEORGIA, GEORGIA, COUNTED ITS
RESULTS THREE TIMES WITH ONE
RECOUNT BY HAND.
PHONY PARTISAN AUDITS WERE
UNDERTAKEN.
LONG AFTER THE ELECTION IN
SEVERAL STATES.
NONE CHANGED THE RESULTS.
AND IN SOME OF THE IRONY, THE
MARGIN OF VICTORY GREW SLIGHTLY.
LET'S SPEAK PLAINLY ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN 2020.
EVEN BEFORE THE FIRST BALLOT WAS
CAST, THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS
PREEMPTIVELY SEWING DOUBT ABOUT
THE ELECTION RESULTS.
HE BUILT HIS LIE OVER MONTHS,
WASN'T BASED IN ANY FACTS.
HE WAS JUST LOOKING FOR AN
EXCUSE, A PRETEXT, TO COVER FOR
THE TRUTH.
HE'S NOT JUST A FORMER
PRESIDENT.
HE'S A DEFEATED FORMER
DEFEATED BY A MARGIN OF OVER 7
MILLION OF YOUR VOTES.
A FULL AND FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
THERE IS SIMPLY ZERO PROOF THE
ELECTION RESULTS WERE
INACCURATE.
IN FACT, IN EVERY VENUE, WHERE
EVIDENCE HAD TO BE PRODUCED, AN
OATH TO TELL THE TRUTH HAD TO BE
TAKEN, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
FAILED TO MAKE HIS CASE.
JUST THINK ABOUT THIS.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS
SUPPORTERS HAVE NEVER BEEN ABLE
TO EXPLAIN HOW THEY ACCEPT AS
ACCURATE THE OTHER ELECTION
RESULTS THAT TOOK PLACE ON
NOVEMBER 3rd.
THE ELECTIONS FOR GOVERNOR,
UNITED STATES SENATE, HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, ELECTIONS WHICH
THEY CLOSED THE GAP IN THE
HOUSE.
THEY CHALLENGED NONE OF THAT.
THE PRESIDENT'S NAME WAS FIRST,
THEN WE WENT DOWN THE LINE.
GOVERNOR, SENATORS, HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, SOMEHOW THOSE
RESULTS WERE ACCURATE ON THE
SAME BALLOT, BUT THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE WAS FLAWED?
ON THE SAME BALLOT, THE SAME
DAY, CAST BY THE SAME VOTERS.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT DIDN'T LOSE THOSE
RACES, HE JUST LOST THE ONE THAT
WAS HIS OWN.
FINALLY, THE THIRD BIG LIE BEING
TOLD BY A FORMER PRESIDENT AND
HIS SUPPORTERS, THAT THE MOB WHO
SOUGHT TO IMPOSE THEIR WILL
THROUGH VIOLENCE ARE THE
NATION'S TWO PATRIOTS.
IS THAT WHAT YOU THOUGHT?
WHEN YOU LOOKED AT THE MOB,
RANSACKING THE CAPITOL,
DESTROYING PROPERTY, LITERALLY
DEFECATING IN THE HALLWAYS.
RIGHTFULLY AND THROUGH THE
DEATHS OF SENATORS AND
REPRESENTATIVES, HUNTING DOWN
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, PATRIOTS,
NOT IN MY VIEW.
TO ME, THE TRUE PATRIOTS WERE
THE MORE THAN 150 AMERICANS WHO
PEACEFULLY EXPRESSED THEIR VOTE
AT THE BALLOT BOX.
THE ELECTION WORKERS WHO
PROTECTED THE INTEGRITY OF THE
VOTE.
AND THE HEROES WHO DEFENDED THIS
CAPITOL.
YOU CAN'T LOVE YOUR COUNTRY ONLY
WHEN YOU WIN.
YOU CAN'T OBEY THE LAW ONLY WHEN
IT IS CONVENIENT.
YOU CAN'T BE PATRIOTIC WHEN YOU
EMBRACE AND ENABLE LIES.
THOSE WHO STORMED THIS CAPITOL
AND THOSE WHO INSTIGATED AND
INCITED AND THOSE WHO CALLED ON
THEM TO DO SO HELD A DAGGER AT
THE THROAT OF AMERICA, AT
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
THEY DIDN'T COME HERE OUT OF
PATRIOTISM OR PRINCIPLE.
THEY CAME HERE IN RAGE.
NOT IN SERVICE OF AMERICA, BUT
RATHER IN SERVICE OF ONE MAN.
THOSE WHO INCITED THE MOB, THE
REAL PLOTTERS WHO WERE DESPERATE
TO DENY THE CERTIFICATION OF
THIS ELECTION, DEFY THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS, BUT THEIR PLOT WAS
FOILED.
CONGRESSMEN, DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS, STAYED.
SENATORS, REPRESENTATIVES,
STAFF, THEY FINISHED THEIR WORK
THE CONSTITUTION DEMANDED.
THEY HONORED THEIR OATH TO
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST
ALL ENEMIES, FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC.
LOOK, FOLKS, NOW IT IS UP TO ALL
OF US TO WE, THE PEOPLE, TO
STAND FOR THE RULE OF LAW, TO
PRESERVE THE FLAME OF DEMOCRACY,
TO KEEP THE PROMISE OF AMERICA
ALIVE.
THAT PROMISE IS AT RISK,
TARGETED BY THE FORCES THAT
VALUE BRUTE STRENGTH OVER THE
SANCTITY OF DEMOCRACY.
FEAR OVER HOPE.
PERSONAL GAIN OVER PUBLIC GOOD.
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT, WE'RE
LIVING AT AN INFLEXION POINT IN
HISTORY.
BOTH HOME AND ABROAD, WE'RE
ENGAGED ANEW IN A STRUGGLE
BETWEEN DEMOCRACY AND AUTOCRACY.
BETWEEN THE ASPIRATIONS OF THE
MANY AND THE GREED OF THE FEW.
BETWEEN THE PEOPLE'S RIGHT OF
SELF-DETERMINATION AND
SELF-SEEKING AUTOCRAT.
FROM CHINA TO RUSSIA AND BEYOND,
THEY'RE BETTING THAT DEMOCRACY'S
DAYS ARE NUMBERED.
TOLD ME DEMOCRACY IS TOO SLOW,
TOO BOGGED DOWN BY DIVISION, TO
SUCCEED IN TODAY'S RAPIDLY
CHANGING COMPLICATED WORLD.
AND THEY'RE BETTING, THEY'RE
BETTING AMERICA WILL BECOME MORE
LIKE THEM AND LESS LIKE US.
THEY'RE BETTING THAT AMERICA IS
A PLACE FOR THE AUTOCRAT, THE
DICTATOR, THE STRONG MAN.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT.
THAT IS NOT WHO WE ARE.
THAT IS NOT WHO WE HAVE EVER
BEEN.
AND THAT IS NOT WHO WE SHOULD
EVER, EVER BE.
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS, AS
IMPERFECT AS THEY WERE, SET A
MOTION AND EXPERIMENT THAT
CHANGED THE WORLD, LITERALLY
CHANGED THE WORLD.
HERE IN AMERICA, THE PEOPLE
WOULD RULE.
POWER WOULD BE TRANSFERRED
PEACEFULLY.
NEVER AT THE TIP OF A SPEAR OR A
BARREL OF A GUN.
AND THEY COMMITTED TO PAPER AN
IDEA THAT COULDN'T LIVE UP TO --
THEY COULDN'T LIVE UP TO, BUT AN
IDEA THAT COULDN'T BE
CONSTRAINED.
YES, IN AMERICA, ALL PEOPLE ARE
CREATED EQUAL.
REJECT THE VIEW THAT IF YOU
SUCCEED, I FAIL.
IF YOU GET AHEAD, I FALL BEHIND.
IF I HOLD YOU DOWN, I SOMEHOW
LIFT MYSELF UP.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WHO LIES
ABOUT THIS ELECTION AND THE MOB
THAT ATTACKED THIS CAPITOL COULD
NOT BE FURTHER AWAY FROM THE
CORE AMERICAN VALUES.
THEY WANT TO RULE OR THEY WILL
RUIN.
RUIN WHAT OUR COUNTRY FOUGHT FOR
AT LEXINGTON AND CONCORD, AT
GETTYSBURG AND OMAHA BEACH,
SENECA FALLS, SELMA, ALABAMA.
AND WHAT WE'RE FIGHTING FOR.
THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
THE RIGHT TO GOVERN OURSELVES.
THE RIGHT TO DETERMINE OUR OWN
DESTINY.
WITH RIGHTS COME
RESPONSIBILITIES, RESPONSIBILITY
TO SEE EACH OTHER AS NEIGHBORS,
MAYBE WE DISAGREE WITH THAT
NEIGHBOR, BUT THEY'RE NOT AN
ADVERSARY.
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACCEPT DEFEAT,
THEN GET BACK INTO THE ARENA AND
TRY AGAIN THE NEXT TIME TO MAKE
YOUR CASE.
RESPONSIBILITY TO SEE THAT
AMERICA IS AN IDEA, AN IDEA THAT
REQUIRES VIGILANT STEWARDSHIP.
AS WE STAND HERE TODAY, ONE YEAR
SINCE JANUARY 6th, 2021, THE
LIES THAT DROVE THE ANGER AND
MADNESS WE SAW IN THIS PLACE,
THEY HAVE NOT ABATED.
SO WE HAVE TO BE FIRM, RESOLUTE
AND UNYIELDING IN OUR DEFENSE OF
THE RIGHT TO VOTE, AND TO HAVE
THAT VOTE COUNTED.
SOME HAVE ALREADY MADE THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE IN THIS
SACRED EFFORT.
JILL AND I HAVE MOURNED POLICE
OFFICERS IN THIS CAPITOL
ROTUNDA, NOT ONCE, BUT TWICE, IN
THE WAKE OF JANUARY OF 6th, ONCE
FOR BRIAN SICKNICK WHO LOST HIS
LIFE THE DAY AFTER THE ATTACK,
AND SECOND TIME TO HONOR OFFICER
BILLY EVANS WHO LOST HIS LIFE
DEFENDING THIS CAPITOL AS WELL.
WE THINK ABOUT THE OTHERS WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES AND WERE
INJURED, AND EVERYONE LIVING
WITH THE TRAUMA OF THAT DAY.
THOSE DEFENDING THIS CAPITOL TO
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS IN BOTH
PARTIES AND THEIR STAFFS, TO
REPORTERS, CAFETERIA WORKERS,
CUSTODIAL WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
DON'T KID YOURSELF.
THE PAIN AND SCARS FROM THAT DAY
RUN DEEP.
SAID IT MANY TIMES, AND IT IS NO
MORE TRUE OR REAL THAN WE THINK
ABOUT THE EVENTS OF JANUARY 6th,
WE ARE IN A BATTLE FOR THE SOUL
OF AMERICA.
A BATTLE THAT BY THE GRACE OF
GOD, THE GOODNESS AND
GRACIOUS -- GREATNESS OF THIS
NATION WE WILL WIN.
BELIEVE ME, I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT
DEMOCRACY IS.
I'M CRYSTAL CLEAR ABOUT THE
THREATS AMERICA FACES.
I ALSO KNOW OUR DARKEST DAYS CAN
LEAD TO LIGHT AND HOPE FROM THE
DEATH AND DESTRUCTION THE VICE
PRESIDENT REFERENCED IN PEARL
HARBOR, FROM THE BRUTALITY OF
BLOODY SUNDAY ON THE EDMUND
PETTUS BRIDGE CAME HISTORIC
VOTING RIGHTS LEGISLATION.
NOW, LET'S STEP UP, WRITE THE
NEXT CHAPTER IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, FOR JANUARY 6th MARKS
NOT THE END OF DEMOCRACY, BUT
THE BEGINNING OF A RENAISSANCE
OF LIBERTY AND FAIR PLAY.
I DID NOT SEEK THIS FIGHT
BROUGHT TO THIS CAPITOL ONE YEAR
AGO TODAY.
BUT I WILL NOT SHRINK FROM IT
EITHER.
I WILL STAND IN THIS BREACH, I
WILL DEFEND THIS NATION, I WILL
NO ONE TO PLACE A DAGGER AT THE
THROAT OF DEMOCRACY.
WE WILL MAKE SURE THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE IS HEARD, THAT THE
BALLOT PREVAILS, NOT VIOLENCE,
BUT AUTHORITY IN THIS NATION
WILL ALWAYS BE PEACEFULLY
TRANSFERRED.
I BELIEVE THE POWER OF THE
PRESIDENCY AND THE PURPOSE IS TO
UNITE THIS NATION, NOT DIVIDE
IT.
TO LIFT US UP, NOT TEAR US
APART.
IT IS ABOUT US, ABOUT US, NOT
ABOUT ME.
DEEP IN THE HEART OF AMERICA
BURNS A FLAME, ALMOST 250 YEARS
AGO, OF LIBERTY, FREEDOM AND
EQUALITY.
THIS IS NOT A LAND OF KINGS OR
DICTATORS OR AUTOCRATS.
WE'RE A NATION OF LAWS, OF
ORDER, NOT CHAOS, OF PEACE, NOT
VIOLENCE.
HERE IN AMERICA, THE PEOPLE
RULE.
THROUGH THE BALLOT, AND THEIR
WILL PREVAILS.
SO LET US REMEMBER TOGETHER
WHERE ONE NATION, UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, THIS TODAY,
TOMORROW AND FOREVER AT OUR BEST
WE ARE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
GOD BLESS YOU ALL.
MAY GOD PROT